What's up? BRUH
(We Are The Caption Artists And We Want To Say Hello!)
(also please feed us pewds)
Today we're trying out something different (:D)
Something that hasn't been done before
We're reviewing the subreddit (:O)
(IT'S TOO DANGEROUS PEWDS DON'T DO IT)
I don't know if you've heard of this
It's called dank memes?
(if a meme is dank a man not only has the right to steal it but is obligated to do so - some scientist nerd)
okay
So is that, like, memes, but
a lil more edgier?
(EDGE LORD OVER HERE)
If you can't handle edgy humor
then the door is right there
(and the window is right there)
and it's free for you to leave, ok?
(But If You Run Into EA You Better Have $10 In Hand)
Now, without further ado,
LET'S JUST JUMP INTO THIS
I can't believe this channel
has absolutely no shame whatso-
(no we do not)
I put on headphones, I don't need it
I've basically become these, uh
text-to-speech Reddit channels at this point
except I have to do the actual effort of reading it out (BANG BANG SHOTS FIRED)
This is the top voted meme and- pretty good
That dog is sneezing, ok?
(or he happy that minecraft is numba one)
Know the context behind the meme
or shut the fr*ck out of my face
me when I make another Reddit video
and my 9 year old audience:
SHAME- oh well I'm trying goddamnit
(no you aren't)
what are you insinuating
I love these
What's the problem?
(Ikr What Casuals)
Shrek babies
Well, if you're dealing with that kind of th*t
(it is incredibly relatable tho)
that has to play some sort of
social media online game with
then maybe she isn't worth it anyway
BROFIST if you're gay
That's right
On this channel
We don't discriminate against LGBTQ+
We acknowledge
BROFIST if you're gay
Can I read English?
smoking some weed there, boi, that's epic
(da de da de da its the one and only
D - O - Double G SNOOP DOGG)
What is happening in Alabama?
They banned the gay right marriage
They can't do that!
Alabama!
Let the gay rat wedding be!
Let the f- I swore!
Let the goddamn gay rat wedding be!
it's so bad
i don't know why I laughed
Alright
so let's get real here
This video is gonna get garbage ads
but I have a way to get past the system
alright
5000 IQ move coming up
The highest valued ads on YouTube are real estate
I'm just gonna say a bunch of words
when the mid-roll rolls
and hopefully, they'll transcribe properly
and get the edit
You should buy a house
Are you looking to buy a house?
If you're looking to buy a house
home insurance
You can buy one for cheap
perhaps get a mortgage
home loans
Click this link and 10% will go to me
home lawyer
Buy a house
buy a very nice house
(yeah and stop being a broke boi *That is a joke*)
you should buy a house
are u thinking?
*1000000000 IQ Plays By Pewds*
you're thinking about buying a house, aren't you
I can tell just by looking at you
home hosting
you want a house, you want a goddamn house, don't you
another house?
2 houses?
3 houses?!
(That's a lie)
That's awesome
BROFIST if you're a gay house
(wot and yes we had to type that
we don't get fed enough for this)
ok
lemme know if you got a real estate commercial
(you better have gotten one)
What in the God's earth is this?
oh god
This reddit has turned into me IRL
congratulations
you did it
oh my god
is that the same kid?
(yup they both insane)
code: pewdiepie
(CODE PEWDIEPIE FOR 10% OFF YOUR PURCHASE)
please
please guys come through this one!!
it glows in the dark
(yes now throw your money away to get it)
you know this has been raised at some board meeting
guys
you all do understand the potential here
look how cute he looks now
you snake
that's lovely to see in other games, being inclusive
this joke is gonna bite me in the ass
it's almost gonna make a compilation
godDAMNIT
you know who else is gonna be 69 years old this year?
my man (now stop copyrighting these videos sony)
coming up soon, my man
*clapping* my bruh, my man,
my honey, my boo, my b*tch, my-
home software
why do they just not get it?
(Idk)
no one wants to talk to you
(yeah jimmy get some real friends)
ok?
if I wanted to talk to you
I would talk to you
(But I Don't)
and if I talked to you
you scum
it's only out of courtesy
and you are supposed to
still understand that and not reply
thank you
bruh
there's breasts in the dictionary?
BORST
that's a soup
you dummy Germans
BRUST
what happened in the 60's huh?
what did you do in the 60's
now we know what happened in the 60's
(that's when all the old people were 12)
glad we got that mystery solved
when you ARE swimming you absolute schmuck
I'm not even English
and you don't even know the difference
between you are and your?
(Disgusting)
dummy dumb
as a fellow Swedish man
I can agree
it's fr**king gross
and we have to climb up the rocks
when we swim and it's all seaweed
(ikr it feels weird)
but then you get over it
but you know what we would do?
we would grab these seaweeds
and we would poke hole- two holes in one of them
and we would tie them around our face
so we could look like the turtles
the Ninja Turtles
it's awesome
sorry to interrupt the video gamers
I just wanted to let you guys know
just letting you guys know
to celebrate our road to 100M subscribers
we are re-releasing all the 50, the 60,
the 70, 80, now the 90M club merch baby
(much wow)
Right now, 60M club is available
very epic
Check it out, collect them all, support the channel
(do it now epic gamers)
because this video is 100% demonetized
(ya think?)
thank you
bye
Why is everyone so obsessed with Minecraft
(Cuz It's a great and memeable game pewds)
like, chill
(or no)
the original
there's so many Elon Musk here
I had never realized
I don't get it, I don't play Minecraft, I'm not a nerd
(then you should have played it
*This is a joke please feed me*)
ok?
incredible
GameBoy Advance, that stuff was some good sh-
I always wondered if that works
*picture of someone taking a FAT rip*
that's funny, okkkkk
if you're preggy right now
don't worry, Thanos isn't real, this is totally fine
as long as you're not in Alabama
(SWEET HOME ALABAMA)
yeah, they're not great, are they?
it's also the fact that
the whole keyboard just ***king
starts heating up too
and you keep your hand there
and then your hand gets all sweaty
from the heat of the laptop
and then it gets, like all
watery
and then your sweat integrates the
internal system
and then everything cools again
oh my god please give me this
I want this
what the hell??
ooh yeah
what is he doing?
(reading something I failed to learn)
one of them is a dictionary or something,
I can understand
but why- how on God's earth is that even possible?
no, that's when you go,
what?
who is this new upcoming actress?
that i've never seen ever before?
basically me
on the whole James Charles stuff
like, boo-
I mean, Poppy Gloria, who's dead
(RIP you legend)
this is so sad
do you want to buy a house?
(yes)
I think you're looking like someone
that wants to buy a house
Could I interest you in some real estate?
Could I interest you in a lifetime of debt?
(Nah I already got that)
hmm?
How about a property?
smash like subscribe
and
can I interest you in buying a property?
what?!
you never played tuber simulator?
you know it's
FUN right?
I'm not supposed to give my opinon
(HOW DARE YOU STAND WHERE SHE STOOD)
but give it a try
and then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet?
k
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available
for FREE
and that's a great price!